people around the world are celebrating
christmas with many refusing to let the
impacts of covet 19 affect the festive
cheer
in australia the first part of the world
to ringing christmas day people flocked
to sydney's glistening bondi beach
as summer temperatures soared stranded
expatriates made the most of it
there's no flights home
i'm uh
i'm celebrating in the best way i can
i love being in australia i love being
in bondi being on the beach for
christmas day it's a dream come true
well what more could you want you've got
fit buddies running up and down the
beach you've got the sand you've got the
water you've got the sunshine where else
could you want to be
people also gathered in bethlehem where
christians believe jesus christ was born
she just was born in bethlehem right
there
so what a better place to come celebrate
his part so it's wonderful the tree
everything is so wonderful so they're
very happy
very joyful bring the joy to the world
[Music]
in india christian communities
celebrated across the country from
hyderabad to new delhi
as did those in south korea china
thailand and the philippines
i'm happy at least we can now hear mass
at our church
before there was no chance to go to
church
that's why we are taking the opportunity
to go to the church while it's still
allowed
firefighters in mexico became santa's
helpers for the day delivering toys to
vulnerable children and their families
while in venezuela volunteers gathered
to feed people facing hunger
in the united states shoppers packed
stores to get their last minute gifts
but not everyone made it home in time
travelers were stranded at airports
across the u.s and the world as
thousands of flights were canceled
a result of staff shortages as coveted
19 affected crew members
this year's christmas wish shared among
most people
that there's no more covet that we can
go back to how we were used to living
that's it what else
in the vatican pope francis reminded the
faithful to be humble and use dialogue
to resolve conflict
and in the gulf the region's biggest
roman catholic cathedral welcomed its
first ever christmas mass
in bethlehem a smaller than usual crowd
gathered to celebrate with a similar
message as everywhere
although the situation is hard with
kovid people want to live and spread joy
all around this year we hope the
coronavirus will disappear there's peace
upon all nations the violence within our
society will end and the atmosphere will
stay as it is now full of love and joy
between everyone
a message of hope reverberating across
nations around the world jillian wolf
al jazeera